[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: So let me
very briefly recap
what we discussed last time.
So we started off thinking
about choices and risk.
How do people think
about economic behavior
when things are uncertain,
when there's risk involved?
I sort of discussed
and showed you
sort of the main workhorse
model that economists
use to study risk.
That's sort of the
expected utility.
That is a very commonly
extremely useful
model for many situations.
So it's like very widely used.
If you ask 100
economists randomly
which model explains
choices [INAUDIBLE]
the majority will
surely tell you expected
utility is what you should use.
It explains a wide range of
phenomena in very useful ways.
You can think about lots
of different things.
You can, for example, think
about investment behavior,
finance.
When you think about what
should you invest in,
if things become more risky,
if assets are more volatile,
you need to have a
higher return for that,
or you need to be
offered a higher
return to invest in those
assets and so on and so forth.
There's lots of useful
applications in finance
using expected utility.
You can think of a range
of different issues.
You can think about, for
example, criminal behavior,
about sort of the risk
of getting caught.
What happens when the
risk of caught goes up?
People engage in less crime
and so on and so forth.
There's lots of
different behaviors
that you can think about and
explain using expected utility.
So I do want you to sort of take
away the expected utility model
is a very useful model
for various applications.
What we're trying
to do is trying
to understand are there some
applications for which perhaps
the expected utility model
has some limitation, perhaps
because of its simplicity
or parsimony because there's
only one parameter in there?
Can we sort of alter
that in some ways
and try to make it more
realistic in some situations?
So the key parameter
of interest when
you try to sort of
estimate this model,
trying to sort of match
the data in some ways,
the parameter that you'd
estimate here is you
need to sort of assume
some functional form.
This is what I did last time.
I can show you this.
So this here, one very
commonly functional form
is the CRRA utility function
that's very widely used
in a lot of range of settings.
The feature of that is it
has a constant relative risk
aversion, and that has a
bunch of useful properties
for estimating things
or making predictions.
So what you then
need to do is you
try to sort of estimate
somebody's risk preferences.
How do people behave under risk?
What you need to do then sort
of assume some functional
form, for example, this
CRRA utility function.
And then the question
is kind of like how
do we estimate gamma the
risk aversion parameter?
That's the key
parameter in this model.
Now, how do you do that?
I showed you some different
choices [INAUDIBLE]..
Essentially we
reveal preference.
Economists believe when
we reveal preference,
I give you some choices
that involve risk.
And depending what
you choose, that
reveals what your gamma is.
So you can do like
small scale gambles,
which is just like small choices
between different options.
Some entail more
risks than others,
and then you can
essentially just
sort of estimate
using those choices,
or people certainty
equivalent for such choices,
what's people's gamma is.
Now, what we found is that when
you have small-scale gambles,
people look or appear
very risk-averse.
They'll often decline gambles
with positive expected value,
which makes them appear
quite risk-averse once you
sort of estimate
this parameter gamma.
Gamma looks like gamma is
above 10, above 20, above 30,
really, really high.
Now, at the same time, you
can look at large-scale risk.
There, when you look
at large-scale choices,
when you sort of think about
what's a reasonable gamma,
people actually only appear
moderately risk-averse.
It doesn't look like they're
particularly risk-averse.
When you sort of think for
those large-scale choices
and we look at finance or
housing or other applications
that people have
estimated such models,
you get like gamma sort of
between 0 and 2 roughly.
Now, what that then
implies is if your gamma is
between 0 and 2, that
means essentially
for small-scale
gambles you should
be essentially risk neutral.
You should not care
about really small risks
that are about a dollar or two.
So that sort of poses a
problem because now we
have sort of two
contradicting answers.
We have for small-scale
risk, it looks like people
are really risk-averse.
For a large-scale gamble it
looks like people are not
so risk-averse.
Now, we only have
like one parameter,
is this gamma, which is
coming from the concavity
of the utility function.
And when we only have
one parameter and sort
of two contradicting
pieces of evidence,
we can't sort of
match both, right?
Because if you match
one, then essentially
you can match the
other and vice versa.
Now, I showed you a little
bit Matthew Rabin's--
what he calls the calibration
theorem, which essentially
is sort of calibrating, showing
in a fairly compelling way
that, in fact, you
can formally show it's
not about sort of assumptions
of a specific utility
function or the like.
For these very sort of
minimal assumptions, which
is just the utility
function is weakly concave,
you can essentially show that
declining small-scale gambles
with positive
expected value implies
that people make absurd choices
when the gambles become larger.
The recitation will
discuss this a bit
in more detail and sort
of walking you exactly,
in somewhat slower speeds,
through the specific example.
Now then, where we
started then last time
was thinking about
insurance choices.
This is a very nice
paper by Justin Sydnor,
and one very nice
feature of this paper
is that it involves
real-world choices.
So it's not like
some lab experiments
with some experiments.
Of course, some people care
a lot about undergrads.
Some people might
say, well, what
are these undergrads
choosing anyway?
What does this have to do
with real-world choices?
I think undergrads are great.
But one might wonder,
like, if you recruit people
into some experiments and you
see some choices, like what
do these choices really reveal?
Like, do we really find that
these choices are predictive
of real-world behaviors?
So one answer to
that is, well, let's
find some data from
the real world.
Let's look at real
choices that people
have made in
real-world settings,
and this is exactly
what Sydnor does.
So what he does is he has this
data set of from a large home
insurance provider.
This is sort of 50,000
standard policies
that are sort of like
representative of what
people choose overall.
And the key outcome of
interest in this study
is like people's
deductible choices.
What's a deductible?
Again, these are expenses
paid out-of-pocket
before the insurer
pays any expenses.
So you have like a
deductibles of $500,
you have a damage
of like $200, you
have to pay it all yourself.
If you have a damage of
$1,000, you pay the 500
and then the insurer
pays the rest.
And so what he has
is he has choices
of a menu of four deductibles
for each customer or client.
So you can see both
people's choice sets,
and you can see people's
preferred options.
And that allows them
to sort of say, well,
if you have four options,
you picked one of them.
That means you preferred that
one over all three others.
So we can sort of
essentially put some bounds
on people's risk aversion.
And so we looked
at this already.
This is kind of what
this roughly looks like.
There are different deductibles,
which is essentially, again,
like how much how much
you have to pay yourself
in case of damage until the
insurance payments kick in.
You have the premium, which
is like how much for sure
you have to pay every year.
And then there is the premium
relative to the $1,000 policy.
How much more expensive is it?
That's in the third column.
How much more expensive is it
to choose a lower deductible
relative to the $1,000 premium?
And then we have people's
choices which is, in this case,
I guess, policyholder one
shows a deductible of $250.
It was a premium
of $661, which is
$157 more expensive than the
$1,000 deductible option.
OK?
And for each
policyholder, the company
was, in fact, sort of
providing individual prices.
So essentially they
were looking at where
do they live, what's the housing
value, and so on and so forth.
Sydnor knows all of that.
So he knows the
full set of options
that people had available
and their actual choices,
and the options
available vary by person.
How do we learn now
about risk aversion?
Well, so the losses
to the customers
are capped by the
deductible, right?
So any loss you have from
any damage that you get,
the losses are only
up to the deductible.
So if you have a
deductible of $500,
the most you can lose or
have to pay in any case
if any loss occurs is $500.
So choosing a lower
deductible then,
what it does it amounts
to essentially reducing
that loss in case
you have a damage.
So if you have a
deductible of $500
and decide to instead choose
a deductible of $250, that
means essentially
in case there's
a damage, in case you
have to pay something,
you don't have to pay 500.
You have to only pay 250.
But of course, if you
lower your deductible,
the price of your insurance
goes up, the premium goes up,
and the premium you
have to pay for sure.
So the way you can
think about this then
is like, if you choose a
lower deductible, for sure
you have to pay more money.
But in case there's
some damage to you
with some probability
that happens,
if you have some
claims, you have
to like pay less because
your deductible is now lower.
OK?
So now what info do
we actually need?
We need the available
deductibles.
Like, essentially what are the
deductibles for each choice?
We need the premium
for each option.
We need the claim probabilities
and people's wealth levels
because you have a
utility function where
there's wealth in there.
I'll talk about
this in one second.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So now one important
feature in this I think
was asked like last
time about like, well,
what about the claim rates?
Well if the claim
rates are really high
or if people think the
claim rates are really
high, in some sense then,
having very low deductibles
makes a lot of
sense because then--
and very often it happens
that you have to pay.
Then it makes lots of sense to
have like lower deductibles.
But it turns out claims
rates are actually very low.
So you can see overall--
this is like the
full sample, this
is everybody-- people's
claim rates is 4.2%.
These are yearly claim rates.
This is like out of 100
customers, 4.2 per year
actually claim any damage.
And then it varies a little bit
also by choice of deductible.
So there's the
people who happened
to choose in the end like
$1,000, $500, $250, and $100.
But for each of them
essentially, the claim rate
is below 5%.
So it's very low.
OK?
The second factor from this data
is that reducing the deductible
is very expensive.
So for example, this is
the full sample again.
On average, purchasing
the insurance
where the deductible
of $1,000 cost $615,
we can't say very
much about that choice
because who knows how much the
actual damages are and so on.
In some sense, that's
sort of irrelevant for us
what that number is.
What we're interested
in is like what
are the differences in costs
of different deductibles?
How much do you have to pay
to lower your deductible
to like $500, $250, and so on?
Now what you see here
is like on average,
reducing the deductible
from $1,000 to $500,
which is sort of what this
column shows that's shown
in red, costs $999.91.
So if you choose then
like $500, is this
is a risk-averse choice or not?
How do we think about that?
Suppose your claim
rate is like, say, 5%.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think it
would be a risk-averse decision
because you're paying $100
more and your deductible
has gone down by $500.
So claim rate for that back
of the envelope calculation
would need to be about 20.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So what you're saying is
you're reducing the deductible
from $1,000 to $500.
Now, if you think that happens
with a 5% chance, on average
you're going to reduce
your payments by $25.
So 5% times $500,
which is a $25.
But people are willing to
pay about $100 for that.
So for sure they're paying $100,
and the benefit that they get
is with 5% chance, at
least the average customer,
with 5% chance they're going
to pay $500 less in case
there's some damage.
That looks already
pretty risk-averse.
Because as Ben
says, surely you're
not risk-neutral, because
then you would not do that.
You would choose the $1,000.
It looks fairly risk-averse.
Now if you go down then, if you
go to like from $250 to $200,
there's an additional $133.22.
So that's to say reducing your
deductible by another $150,
from $250 to $100, makes you
for sure you have to pay $133.
And now if your chance is like
5% of getting like essentially
a damage, that is for a
5% chance of saving $150,
people are willing
to pay $133 for sure.
OK?
So now if you try to calibrate
this, what we already
know from this,
the simple example
is that people look
extremely risk-averse.
OK?
So that's kind of like the
exercise that Sydnor is doing,
just saying, look, let's take
these choices very seriously.
Let's look what people have
done in real-world situations.
These are repeat
customers, people
who have done this for
a long time and so on.
What are people choosing?
And if you sort of assume
expected utility, what would
people's gamma need
to look like to be
able to explain this data?
And we can do this customer--
this is like the average rates.
They can do this sort
of customer by customer.
Now, what he then finds
is the majority of people
choose small deductibles.
Lots of people
choose $250, $500.
Very few people choose
$1,000, even among people,
and this is on the x-axis,
who have been at the company
for 15-plus years.
You would say like the
first time you do this,
maybe you don't understand
your claim rate,
you don't understand what's
going on or whatever.
But there's people who have been
at this company for 15 years.
They should kind of
know at some point
that claim rates are pretty
low, at least on average.
And so like if you have
15 years at this company,
it's hard to believe that you'd
still think that your claim
rate is, say, about
10% or the like
since it just doesn't
happen very often.
OK.
Now, how do we think about
people choosing a deductible?
Again, what you need is like
the following parameter.
You need to have
the yearly premium.
You need to have the
deductible D. You're
assuming no other risks
to lifetime wealth, which
is a bit of a distraction,
but essentially you
can diversify risk and
so on and so forth.
You also can assume that's
at most one risk per year.
This is, again, sort
of simplification
and doesn't really matter very
much for the probability pi.
And then for now
at least, we assume
accurate, subjective beliefs
about the likelihood of a loss.
Now then, what is then the
indirect utility function
of wealth?
What does the
utility function look
like depending on
these parameters?
Can somebody explain this
what I'm showing here?
What is this equation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The first part
says pi [INAUDIBLE] w
minus P minus D. The
w minus P minus D
is your wealth if
something happens.
[INAUDIBLE] pi.
And the 1 minus pi is on
your utility of your wealth
if nothing bad happens.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So for sure, so with probability
1 minus pi, nothing happens.
You have your wealth
W that you had before.
You have to pay the
premium for sure.
So in that case, you also
have to pay the premium.
So you're going to end up
with W minus P, the premium.
And then with
probability pi, you also
have to pay the premium,
which is W minus P,
but also you have to
pay the deductible
because some damage occurred.
All right.
And then your indirect
utility-- your expected utility
for that year is
essentially then
the weighted average
of these things.
And pi is essentially
the weight on that,
which is the subjective
or, in this case,
assumed actual probability
of a damage occurring.
Now, I sort of said the
indirect utility function,
utility of wealth
function, what is that?
What's A, an indirect
utility function?
And B, why is there wealth
in it and not consumption?
Usually we think
people eat stuff
and there should be
like consumption here.
Why do we have wealth in here?
What is this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think they might
be like assuming [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
What is the indirect
utility function?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So usually you think what
you do is if you go back
to like 14.01 notes or
what was done in the first
I think recitation,
usually what you
do is you maximize
consumption with several goods
or one good or
whatever over time,
and usually there's
a budget constraint
and wealth is usually in your
budget constraint, right?
You can only consume as much
as how much money you have.
Could be like your
income or your wealth
if it's over your lifetime.
Now when you do that
and maximize it,
then you end up at an optimum.
What you can then do is
like essentially express
the optimum.
Assuming that you
have chosen optimally,
your consumption is
saying you already
chose whether you wanted
apples or bananas or whatever.
If we assume that you optimize,
I can then essentially just say
assuming that you're
optimizing, what
is your optimized utility for
different levels of wealth?
And usually it's a function
of wealth and prices,
and that's what the indirect
utility function is.
We can very briefly also
go over that in recitation.
But if you go back to
your 1401 or other notes,
you will see
essentially that it's
the outcome of a
maximization problem.
Usually it's like for
two goods or whatever.
Like, it's like income.
In this case, it's wealth
because it's like over--
Yeah, it's wealth, but it
could be available income
as well if you wanted.
Now, what the person
is then going to do
is like each contract gives you
an expected utility in terms
of how much do you expect your
utility to be if you choose
that specific contract.
And now the maximization
problem is now
you choose the contract J
that maximizes the expected
utility or the expected
indirect utility as a function
of these parameters.
Any questions on this?
So for each contract,
we can write down what's
the indirect utility function.
It depends on people's wealth.
So we have to make
some assumption
of how wealthy people are.
And it depends on
these other parameters.
It depends on the premium,
it depends on the deductible,
and it depends on the subjective
probability of a claim
occurring in that year.
We assume that there's
only one claim per year.
OK.
So now what we can do is then
we can back out the implied risk
aversion from people's choices.
And in fact, what
we can do is we
can get upper and lower bounds
on people's risk aversion
from what they have chosen.
Let me sort of give you
an example for that.
Suppose a person chooses
a $100 deductible.
What does this mean?
Well, this means essentially
that he or she preferred
the $100 deductible over all
the other deductibles that
were available.
Right?
So essentially, if
you choose the 100,
you get three inequalities.
You get like the $100
deductible is better
than the $250
deductible, the $100
is better than $500
deductible, and $100 is
better than $1,000 deductibles.
Now, this gives us a bound
on people's risk aversion.
Is it the lower or an
upper bound and why?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think it's a lower
bound because $100 [INAUDIBLE]
is like the lowest you can
go in a lower deductible
can cause more risk-aversion.
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly.
Sort of like a corner solution.
So like, if the person
who chooses $100--
that's the person that I
just showed you previously.
This is the example
that I showed you here.
Where was it?
This is a person who looks
extremely risk-averse, right?
This is a person
essentially saying
like, I'm choosing the
lowest possible deductible.
I'm for sure paying
quite a bit of money
compared to all these other
options, 4% or 5% chance
of not having a damage.
So this person will
look very risk-averse.
It's the lowest possible option.
So maybe the person, if there
had been a $50 or zero dollars
option, would have even
chosen that option.
We don't know because
that's not available.
What you can then
do is, however, you
can just write down
these inequalities.
And so if you choose
the $100 deductible
compared to the
$250 deductible, it
will be the case that
if you solve for gamma,
this gives you a lower
bound for or gamma.
So what does that mean?
We know that gamma
is at least as high
as the solution of this
inequality will tell us,
but in fact, their gamma
could be even higher.
We just don't know it because we
don't have additional choices.
Now, if you choose the $1,000
deductible on the other hand,
you'll get like an upper bound.
The reasoning is
exactly the same.
Essentially, if you choose
the $1,000 deductible,
that's like the
riskiest option you
can choose because
essentially you're
choosing something
you will choose not
to reduce your risk in any way.
So you're not willing
to pay to do that.
It's kind of like
accepting a gamble
and not choosing
the safe options.
But we don't know
whether this person would
have chosen like $1,000
on one deductible,
or $2,000, or $5,000,
what deductible would
have been chosen because
there's no other options
of deductibles.
And then in between, we
have essentially lower
and upper bounds,
because essentially we
know that if you
choose 500, we know
that you didn't choose
1,000, and we know also
that you didn't choose 250.
So your gamma must be in
between those options whatsoever
as implied by those two options.
There's a previous problem
set that we posted that sort
of walks you through that.
We'll also go through
that in recitation
to go through the
mechanics of that.
Any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think that's not
a problem because it's just
sort of flipped.
So we have the gamma--
that's why you have the gamma
in the denominator as well.
So you get a problem
if your gamma is 1,
because in dividing
by 1, usually people
use a log utility for that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's
a great question.
So I'll get to this in a second.
So what I have done
right now, and this
is the typical way economists
think about these things,
is sort of say, let's take
a model very seriously.
Here's the model
that I'm using to try
to explain people's
choices, and I'm essentially
assuming everything else away.
I'm essentially assuming
that the person optimizes.
Those no mistakes.
There's no framing of facts.
There's no other stuff going
on, liquidity constraints
and so on.
And I'm taking this
very seriously.
I'm estimating gamma.
Now, the typical-- and this
is section four of the paper,
in fact--
the typical thing
then that happens
is other people are
going to say like, well,
what about if people don't
understand what they're doing?
What about people
misperceiving the risk?
What about people framing
effects in terms of the way
you present the choices?
People like to not choose
extremes, but like to choose
and the middle.
Can that explain the results?
There's some
concerns about that.
I think one thing that your
explanation, for example,
would be able perhaps to explain
is people choosing $500 over
like $1,000.
It's hard for the
framing effects
to explain why people
are choosing 250.
So if you look at this figure
in particular, the people who
are in the company for
15 years, lots of people
choose deductibles of 250.
It's a little bit harder to
explain with framing effects.
Why wouldn't you choose
like 500 as opposed to 250?
Sydnor argues that's
really not what's going on.
I think at the end
of the day, probably
it's the case that people
do not want these extremes
and, to some
degree, I think some
of what's going
on in this perhaps
at least contributed by some
form of framing effect, maybe
marketing.
People who sell the insurance
choices really want people--
they get paid presumably
if they sell essentially
these low deductibles because
that's how the company makes
a lot of money.
What Sydnor says there
is like, well, it's
actually hard to sell people
on stuff that they don't like.
It seems like people really
seem to want these things,
and maybe some of that is sort
of sales pressure, but probably
not everything.
So I think some of
what is going on
is a little bit hard to rule
out all of those things,
but if you read the
paper it's reasonable.
And since it's what I'm
going to show you next
is like the implied
gamma's like so large
that even if you sort of
said, OK, half of this effect
is driven by other things,
you would get still
like really absurdly large
estimates of risk aversion.
But that's a great question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, to some
degree, in some sense,
I think the way they sort of--
The question was like, is
the company deliberately
giving people choices that leads
them to choose low deductibles?
And therefore, do we sort of
overestimate people's gamma?
To some degree,
yes, but it's not
like just we have low
deductibles available.
There's a $1,000
option available.
I think maybe what
you're alluding
to is like there's some sales
pressure and so on going on.
That may well be
true, and people
sort of might emphasize risk
and make it particularly salient
and make customers nervous and
say like, look, these floods
and so on are going on,
and really, low deductibles
are good.
I think to some
degree, that's true,
but you have to be pretty
compelling in your reasoning.
One other comment
is like, there's
lots of other examples of
people choosing low deductibles
and sort of extended
warranties and so on.
And in lots of
cases, for example,
if you look at like iPhones or
iPads and so on and so forth,
laptops, et cetera,
Apple in particular,
but other companies try to
sell extended warranties
that, if you actually did
this exact same calculation,
are not worth
engaging in or that
reveal essentially extreme
risk aversion among customers.
I myself am looking at
this kind of research.
There's lots of research that
argues that people shouldn't
choose extended warranties.
Of course, then when I bought
a laptop the last time,
I was like, of course I don't
need extended warranties.
And then, of course, soon after,
the laptop broke and so on,
and I didn't have a
warranty and so on.
So of course, in specific
examples that may happen,
but on average it's
not a good idea to do.
OK.
So now what does Sydnor find?
So now here in this table, you
can see the implied estimates
of gamma.
Remember, what we
said is what we think
is a reasonable gamma is
somewhere between 0 and 2
for large-scale choices.
He has different
types of assumptions.
He has like lower bounds
and upper bounds of gammas.
And what essentially you
see is the gammas are like,
depending what the assumptions
are, in the hundreds
or in the thousands.
It depends a little bit
what people's wealth is.
So essentially depending on
how much you assume people--
So the data that
he does not have
is what is people's
wealth actually like.
How much money do
people actually have?
So he makes some reasonable
assumptions by saying,
look, these are people whose
houses are like $200,000,
$300,000, $400,000 worth.
So presumably, and we
know from other data
sets roughly how much money
people have available.
So then depending on essentially
what utility function
you assume, he is mostly
using like CRRA utility,
like then is wealth
of like $1,000,000.
You can look at like $100,000,
$50,000, $5,000, and so on.
You can also use CARA utility,
which is constant absolute risk
aversion, and so on.
And essentially, what
you have to assume
is like extremely low levels of
wealth or something like $5,000
to get into like
sort of single digits
or double digits of gamma.
It's extremely
hard to sort of get
estimates that are
reasonable in the sense
that we think are actually
reasonable parameters of gamma.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So now, why do people choose
those small deductibles?
And this is what you
were saying before.
So one classical
explanation would
be, well, they must be
really, really risk-averse.
Their gamma must be really high.
There you might
sort of say, well,
we know already that
gamma shouldn't be that
high from some other choices.
So that's sort of
hard to reconcile.
Was there a question?
No.
Second, you could say,
well, there's really
high objective
probability of claims.
We know that the objectives
for probabilities
are only 4% or 5%.
You'd have to sort
of have probabilities
of claims that are
like 20%, 30%, 40%
to be able to match these data.
Now, it be that people
have risk misperception.
It could be that
people really think
the probability is actually 20%
when it's, at the end, only 5
or 4.
Now, what's sort of
inconsistent with that
is that like repeat
customers, people that
have been at the company
for 10, 15, 20 years,
are making very similar choices.
In some sense, it's hard
to reconcile that everybody
is misperceiving this risk
year after year after year
and spending lots of money.
There's some questions on
is it borrowing constraint?
Is it like people just
don't have enough money?
Are they worried about having
to pay these deductibles?
That also seems quite
unlikely because in fact,
the deductibles
are particularly--
we're not talking
about like $5,000.
People could sort
of, if they really
faced these borrowing
constraints,
they could save and so on.
So Sydnor also argues
that that's not going on.
There's some questions about
marketing social pressure
and so on, which is--
of course, the company has
very much like incentives
to sell people these
kinds of deductibles.
I think some of that
is probably going on,
and it's hard to
rule out entirely.
Again, like, it's hard to
actually sell people stuff they
don't really want to.
So there must be lots of social
pressure to, in fact, do that.
Menu effects.
Already talked about
it a little bit.
There we think that
maybe menu effects
can explain why
people choose to 500
or, like the interior choices,
why they don't choose 1,000.
It's hard to explain
with menu effects
why people choose 50 over 500.
So then Sydnor's
preferred explanation
is then reference-dependent
preferences and loss aversion,
which we're going
to talk about next.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there any data
on whether the probability
of the claim is correlated with
which menu option the people
chose?
PROFESSOR: Yes, there is.
So you have it here.
So it's sort of weakly
correlated in a sense.
Like, if you choose--
or weekly negatively correlated.
So people who choose $1,000 have
2.5% claim rates, and the $100
are 4.7.
So that's kind of not quite
explaining things either.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think the use
of [INAUDIBLE] regression
to control for fact that
those with lower deductibles
may claim multiple times.
PROFESSOR: I see.
Yes.
Great, yes.
OK.
So what do we learn from this?
I think this is very
much sort of confirming
some of the lab evidence data on
relatively small-scale gambles.
These are not like small-scale
gambles of like a dollar
or 2 or 5 or 10.
These are about several
hundreds of dollars,
but they're not about hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
So these are relatively small
relative to like people's
lifetime wealth.
And what we see for
those kinds of choices is
it really looks
like people appear
to be very, very risk-averse.
This is what I was saying
already previously.
When looking at sort of
reasonably small-scale
choices--
and I count the Sydnor evidence
as reasonably small-scale
choices because it's not about
like hundreds of thousands
of dollars--
you essentially see
that such choices imply
people seem very risk-averse.
These choices imply
enormous risk aversion
for large-scale risks.
But people are not avoiding
all sorts of large-scale risks.
People take on lots
of large-scale risk.
So in some sense, that
can't be true in some ways.
We also find that
individuals are moderately
risk-averse a large-scale risk.
People are taking on
some risk, as I said.
Now, if you sort of
take that seriously
and say, well, people might not
be risk-averse, that in turn
implies that people are
nearly risk-neutral.
They should be
nearly risk-neutral
for small-scale risk.
So it can't be that
both of these things
are true at the same time.
Now, in fact, there's
a much older paper
that's a very famous and seminal
paper by Kahneman and Tversky.
Kahneman got the
Nobel Prize, in fact,
for this work and similar work.
Kahneman is a
psychologist and they
were doing psychology
experiments,
and it just turned out that
these psychology experiments
they're extremely influential in
affecting how economists think
about risk and risk
preferences, and in particular,
sort of preference-dependent
preferences.
And so what Kahneman and Tversky
were doing at the time way
before a lot of this
other literature
that I just showed you--
A, they showed even
more sort of evidence
against the expected
utility model.
But perhaps more
importantly, they also
proposed an alternative
model in saying,
look, here's some
choices that we
think are hard to explain
and hard to rationalize
using expected utility.
Now here's a different model
that can explain things perhaps
better in some situations.
So what did Kahneman
and Tversky actually do?
The experiments are
actually extremely
simple in various ways.
They're very clever
and very clean,
but actually very simple.
And so what do these
experiments look like?
These are survey responses.
Like, essentially
they just asked
people about what would you
do in different situations.
This is not what economists
were doing at the time.
Economists at the
time were saying
like, revealed
preferences are important.
I need to make you
do actual choices.
Whatever you say
in surveys doesn't
matter because who knows whether
you actually mean what you say.
It turns out that the survey
responses are actually--
these are hypothetical
stakes, but it turns out
that if you do this
with actual stakes,
you find very similar results.
And the experiments
were as follows.
There were things like questions
like, which of the following
would you prefer, kind of like
I showed you in the first class
at the end of the
survey that you did.
Would you prefer
option A, which is
a 50% of winning $1,000 or
50% chance of winning nothing,
versus option B is
like $450 for sure?
And so they did a series of
these types of questions.
Now, one of the
things that then they
showed is one key prediction
of expected utility
is that, as I said
before, people only
care about final outcomes and
their associated probabilities.
Kahneman and
Tversky show a bunch
of different striking
contradictions of that.
I want you to focus on the first
row-- problem three and problem
three prime.
And look at that and
tell me what of that
example is contradicting
expected utility.
I don't know if
you can see this.
So let me just read this
for you if it's hard to see,
but think of them for a second.
Problem three says,
"Would you prefer
an 80% chance of $4,000
over $3,000 for sure?"
What do you see below then?
These are always 100 people.
You see the number of
people who preferred
one option over the other.
So 80 people preferred
the 3,000 option.
20 people said I'd rather
have the 80% chance of $4,000.
That's problem three.
Problem three
prime is about what
they call negative prospects.
Would you prefer an 80%
chance of losing $4,000,
or for sure losing $3,000?
And there you see 92% choose
the first option and 80%
choose the $3,000 loss for sure.
Let's start with
the left example.
What did we learn
from the left example?
Are people risk-averse,
risk-neutral, risk-loving,
or what have we
learned from that?
AUDIENCE: Risk-averse.
PROFESSOR: Risk-averse,
and why is that?
AUDIENCE: If you calculate
the expected monetary value,
I guess you would
expect to [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we said before
somebody is risk neutral
if the person is indifferent
between two options
when they have the same
expected monetary value.
And so in this case,
an 80% chance of $4,000
is $3,200 in expectation, right?
But there's a bunch
of people who say,
I'd rather get the $3,000, which
is less than 3,200, for sure.
Which means essentially
they take a surer--
like an option that's
for sure they get.
They prefer that
over the uncertainty
of getting 0 versus 4,000,
which on average gets them more,
3,200.
Expected utility would say
if you choose that option,
it must be that you
are risk-averse.
Now, not everybody
seems risk-averse.
There's 80 people out
of 100 choose that,
or I think it's 80% choose
that and the remaining ones
choose the other option.
These other people we
don't know much about.
They're not very
risk-averse, but they
could be also risk-averse
just like it was
revealed in their choice there.
OK.
So from the left
side, we say we know
at least 80 people, or 80% of
the sample, is risk-averse.
Now let's look at
the right side.
What do you see
on the right side?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, they seem
to be risk [INAUDIBLE],,
because unexpected risk minus
3,200 versus minus 3,000,
but they prefer the minus
3,200 on expectation.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you look at the left
option, it's minus 3,200.
So the left option
has more risk,
and it also has a lower
expected monetary value.
As you said in the
expected monetary value,
it's just a flip of
the problem three.
It's minus 3,200, and the
other one is minus 3,000.
So if you're in a
risk-neutral, surely you
would choose the minus 3,000.
If instead you choose
the minus 3,200, well,
it must be that you really
appreciate that there
is additional risk there.
So it looks like
you're risk-loving.
OK.
And now we find here
that 92% of the sample
choose the first option,
but at the same time,
with the same people, when
they're offered or given
the choice between problem
three, 80% of people
choose the other option.
So there are a bunch
of people essentially
that choose the $3,000
for sure in problem three.
At the same time, they
choose the minus 4,000
with an 80% chance when
given problem three prime.
So that means essentially
we have two choices here.
One choice says people
are risk-averse.
The other choice says
people are risk-loving.
In expected utility terms in
our world, this cannot happen.
The reason being that we have
one parameter, which is gamma.
Gamma tells us how
risk-averse or how risk-loving
or the risk-neutral alike.
That parameter
tells us everything
about your risk
preferences for all choices
that I'm giving you.
It cannot be that you're
simultaneously risk-loving
and risk-averse.
So this evidence essentially
sort of rejecting the expected
utility model or cannot
explain this behavior.
Does this make sense?
I sort of wrote this
down here, but I
think I said everything
that's to be said.
Any questions on this?
So where we're going
to go is essentially A,
these people seem to
be behaving differently
for gains versus
losses and, in addition
to that, so not only do people
seem to dislike losses--
I'll show you some
evidence of that--
but in addition, people seem
to be risk-loving for losses
and risk-averse for gains.
And that's kind of what Kahneman
and Tversky are claiming.
And once you make
that claim, you'll
be able to explain these
patterns in the data.
Now, a second thing that
they show is the following.
They show in problem
11 and problem 12.
I'll let you read
it for yourself.
And essentially,
you see that 84%--
so the choice here is in
addition to whatever you have,
for sure you're
going to be given
$1,000, or shekels I guess.
You are now asked to choose
between 1,000 with a 50% chance
and 500 for sure.
OK?
84% say option B.
Problem two is, in addition
to whatever your own,
you have been given 2,000.
You're now asked to
choose between option
C, which is minus
1,000 with 50% chance,
and option D,
which is minus 500.
69% of people here say
they choose option C. OK?
So what's the problem with this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
at the end of it,
you would say that
problem 11 option
B, you end up with 1,500.
Whereas problem 12 option B,
you still end up with 1,500.
People were inconsistent
with these decisions
based on how the
question's framed.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So framing matters, or
reference to points matter.
And so what assumption of
the expected utility model
is that rejecting?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So we postulated that only
final outcomes matter.
Here, if you write
this down, it turns out
option A and option C are
exactly the same in terms
of final outcomes.
Turns out option B and D
are also exactly the same.
I'll let you look at
this for a second.
So A and C are the same in
terms of the final outcomes.
B and D are also
exactly the same
in terms of final outcomes.
So that means essentially when
you compare A versus B and C
versus D, If you only
cared about final outcomes,
you cannot choose different
things here in this lottery.
It cannot be that your utility
is defined over just final
outcomes, because you just
told me you like two different
things for the exact same thing.
And there's 84% who choose
option B while 69% choose
option C. So there's a bunch of
people who essentially switch.
Is that clear?
OK.
So now, what is that?
What's going on here?
Well, where we're going
to go is like well,
it seems like, exactly as
you say, framing matters.
How you frame the
problem matters,
but why does it matter?
Well, it's because we setting
like a reference point.
In the first place,
in the first example,
the reference point is like
1,000 and there is like a gain
relative to 1,000.
We look at like people evaluate
this gamble as like gains.
In the second example,
the reference point
is set to like 2,000, and
now people essentially
evaluate this gamble as
losses relative to the 2,000.
And of depending
on how people think
about gains versus
losses, it turns out
that people make
different choices.
I'll be more formal about
this, but that's essentially
the idea of, like in
Kahneman and Tversky,
their prospect
theory they proposed,
why can explain these behaviors
as opposed to expected utility?
OK.
So now what are sort of
the most important points?
There's three of them.
I'm going to show
you two and then get
to the third one at the end.
So one is like what matters
a lot for people's behaviors
is changes rather than levels.
So what they argue is utility
is not defined by people's final
status-- how much
they end up with--
but as opposed to
like how much changes
relative to some
reference point.
That could be changes
relative to like a status quo.
How much do I have
right now and how much
does it change
positively or negatively?
Or, it could be relative
to some expectation
or some other reference point.
What I showed you
here in this example
is like this is not the status
quo that people evaluate
their utility against because
the outcome is always the same.
The reference point here is
kind of like the expectation
I sent you and say,
OK, here's 1,000.
And now what seems
to be happening
is that people's expectations,
in fact, become 1,000.
And then relative
to that expectation,
people are going to
evaluate gains and losses.
And similarly, if I give
you-- like, say you get 2,000,
again, people will
evaluate the utility
or the outcomes as gains
and losses relative to that.
Second, there seems
to be loss aversion.
Losses loom larger than gains.
That is to say people
dislike a loss that's
as large as a gain by a lot
more than they like the gain.
OK?
So it's like if you say you
lose 100 versus you gain 100,
people really dislike
losing 100 a lot more
than they like gaining 100.
And once you sort
of postulate that,
well then, that can explain why
you reject a bunch of gambles.
Because if say if the gamble is
like minus 10 with 50% chance
and plus 11 with
50% chance, well,
if you dislike the losses
a lot more, if you dislike
losing $10 a lot more than
gaining $10 or $11, well then,
you're going to
reject this gamble
even if the expected
value is positive.
OK?
We'll write down sort of like
a utility function next time.
That's sort of does
this more formally,
but essentially those
are the two key areas.
There's a third one, which I'm
going to get to in a second.
Now, the key part here is
like there is essentially
reference dependence.
People evaluate their outcomes
relative to some reference
point.
What kinds of examples
do we actually
have a reference point?
When you look in the
world-- and again,
that's kind of very much
what I'd like you to do--
when you think about things
that you see in the world,
what kinds of examples do
we have that people care
about reference points as
opposed to final outcomes?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My first thought was,
you know how we have to pay
$0.10 for shopping bags?
Where I was from a
couple years ago,
we did it so that if
you used a reusable bag,
you got $0.05 back.
That was like not effective.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So exactly.
When you think about pricing
of different options,
it matters a lot to people.
It seems that when
you add $0.05,
were to subtract $0.05
or $0.10 or whatever,
the same changes about like
it's just $0.05 at the end
of the day that you have
to pay more or less,
depending on whether
you use a bag,
your choice of using a bag
versus not should not be
affected by whether it's framed
or put as like a loss versus
a gain or like a whatever rebate
or whatever that you might get.
And I think that's true
for many different-- that's
true for shopping plastic bags
or any other shopping bags,
but it's also true for
many other options.
It depends a lot whether you
sort of add on that option
or whether you get
sort of essentially
subtracted the option
as some discount.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
I think some of it
is not exactly--
I think there's some
legal constraints
to that specific behavior
because you're not
supposed to sort of trick
people, but surely some of that
is going on.
People love discounts.
Like, they love
making good deals.
They love sort of
getting things cheaper
in various ways compared
to some reference point.
And the reference
point, since it's
hard to tell what actually
should the price be,
is often like the
previous price.
It's something that
seems really expensive
and now they're getting
it for less money.
And so if you get it
for half the price,
even if it's still
quite expensive,
you think like you saved
half of the price somehow.
AUDIENCE: So how
you feel about what
you have may depend on what
you see your neighbor having.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So reference points
could not just
be prices or sort of
things that affect yourself
in certain ways, and price
is the key example overall.
The reference point could
just be your environment,
your social environment.
We kind of talk about
this to some degree
also when we talk about
social preferences.
People care a lot
about what others do,
and their reference
point might very much
be formed by what
their neighbors do.
Like, how big is their house?
How big is their car?
Do they have a
swimming pool or not?
It could be also like
your neighbor's-- like,
how good are they at school?
Are they smart,
how good looking?
And so on and so forth.
So when people evaluate
certain outcomes,
they often don't evaluate
the levels, but rather
kind of how much
another person makes
or whatever other
people's outcomes are.
And part of the
reason might be that
like evaluating absolute
outcomes is really hard.
It's very hard to
actually understand.
Is $10,000, $50,000,
$100,000, a million--
how much money do you
actually need to be happy
or that you like, or
what kinds of outcomes
are you excited about and so on?
But it's much easier to
say you have something
and another person does not
or the other way around.
It's much easier to
compare with others.
It's very hard to actually
evaluate absolute outcomes,
because who knows how you
should feel about that.
Much easier to say
I have this, they
don't, or the other way around.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: People
sometimes don't want
to let go of fallen
stock they own
because they don't want to see
that they sold at a good price.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
That's called what people
call the disposition effect.
There's actually
pretty large literature
studying this and
lots of debates
on whether it's really
going on or not,
how important it is,
and so on and so forth.
But sort of one
very basic stylized
fact is that when people are
looking at stocks that they
might want to sell, they
are much more likely to sell
winners compared to losers.
Now, why is that bad, or
should you not do that?
AUDIENCE: Is that because
the winners [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: There's
a bit of a question
of is there like momentum
or reversal or the like.
But if you believe in
efficient markets, which
many economists do,
or at least some
of them who are in Chicago--
if you believe in
efficient markets,
then the current stock
price should essentially
not be-- or like
the previous losses
and so on should not be
informative of what's
going on in the future.
So in expectations, your
losers and your winners,
if there's any information
about the future,
about the future valuation,
that should already
be incorporated in the price.
So if you look at
two stocks, one
lost some money and
one gained some money,
they're equally likely
to make you money.
And so if anything, what
they show in these papers
is like there's momentum.
This is what you're saying
is that the winners actually
are, in fact, going to be more
likely to try to increase value
compared to the losers.
But people tend to essentially
want to sort of realize gains.
People seem to be happy
about making gains.
They seem to be very
reluctant to sell the losers,
and there's some questions on
how costly is that actually,
but that's a very robust
pattern in the data.
The same is also true--
I'm going to show you
on Monday, the same
is also true for houses.
People are much less
likely to sell their house
when it has lost value compared
to when it gained value.
I'm controlling for
a bunch of things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
that's a little tricky.
There might be other things
going on, but exactly.
It could just be that like
if you don't go to a movie
when you have bought
a ticket yourself,
it's sort of perceived as a loss
and you really don't like that.
It's a little
complicated to think
about this in simple terms,
because in some sense,
the loss is still there.
But anyway, yeah, exactly.
It's like you lost money.
It's almost like as if
you lost the movie ticket
and didn't get
some value from it.
There's a bit of a question
whether you sort of integrate
these two things or not
because people think
about monetary terms
versus other things often
in separation, but I think
some of that is exactly.
People feel like they have
a loss if they don't take
advantage of the movie tickets.
So I'm going to show you some
examples that are actually
much more basic in some ways.
When you think about
like visual illusions,
this is what's called like
the size contrast illusion.
So one of those
things is like when
you look at circles
or things that's
supposed to look the same,
and in fact are the same size,
they look quite different.
Depending on what you
contrast things with,
things look quite different.
For example, if you look at
these circles in the middle,
they're in fact
exactly the same size,
but in fact, they don't
really look like that.
Similarly, if you look
at these two circles,
it's perhaps more stark.
These circles are, in
fact, exactly the same size
that are in the middle.
Every time I'm
teaching this class,
I sort of have to convince
myself that they are actually
the same size.
So I print it out
and sort of measure
to make sure that it's actually
the same size, and they are.
I checked.
But when you see this, even
if you know it's an illusion,
it's very hard to convince
yourself that it's not.
But they are the same size.
When you look at
these bars, when
you look at the upper black
bar and the lower black bar,
again, it seems like somehow
the upper one is like wider,
but in fact, it's
not, and again, it's
all about the contrast
to the other side.
There's this one which
throws me off the most.
When you look at fields A and
B, they are the same color.
That's hard to believe
once you see it.
They are actually
the same color,
and again, I would print
it out and actually
put them next to each other.
They are the exact same color.
I checked.
There's also a
video that you can
watch that sort of shows this.
And exactly what's
happening is the way
we perceive colors is
coming from contrast, right?
So like black does not or gray
doesn't look as gray when white
or darker gray is next to it.
Similarly here, if you look
at the gray of this bar,
this is the exact same gray.
Again, you can print it
out and sort of look at it.
It's the exact same.
When you look at
it, it just does
look like on the right side
it's darker than on the left.
Now, there's plenty of examples
of reference dependence
for vision.
There's tons of them.
They're kind of
quite interesting.
At some level, it tells us
something about the brain.
Like, in some ways, we can learn
about essentially the way we
evaluate certain outcomes
overall is essentially--
it's much easier for us, or
we think about in contrast,
it's very hard for us often
to think about levels.
But of course, that's vision.
So in some sense, what did we
learn really about utility?
One thing you can look at is
bronze and silver medal winners
at the Olympics.
Presumably or arguably,
winning a silver medal
is better than a
bronze medal winner.
If you look at these
two women, one of them
won the silver medal,
one of them won bronze.
So what people have done
and psychologists have done
is like took actually
a bunch of pictures
from like ceremonies of
bronze and silver winners
and just looked at
who looks happier.
And when you do
that, essentially
the bronze medalists look on
average happier than the silver
medalists.
Presumably it's because
they just missed gold
while the other person
sort of won bronze
because it's great to be
third as opposed to fourth.
And there's more.
You can read more about this,
but that's sort of like one
finding.
Now, it's true for lots
of different feelings,
perceptions,
judgment, and so on.
People compare stimuli
in various ways
when it comes to
temperature, when
it comes to all sorts of things
relative to reference levels.
It's very hard for them to
evaluate it in absolute terms.
So it's easy to say--
when you look at water,
it's very hard to say
what's the temperature
even if you sort of
practice it a lot.
It's very easy to say
one bucket of water
is warmer than another.
It's very hard to sort of say
it's like 70 degrees or 60
or whatever.
It's very hard to
sort of understand
what absolute
temperatures are, and I
think that's the same in some
ways for a lot of consumption
or other decisions.
It's very hard to say how
much would you pay for this
or how happy should I be
with certain outcomes,
because people need
some reference,
and often then the
reference are either
some expectations,
or their neighbors,
or just comparing between
different options.
So that's the example
I mentioned previously,
which is it's much
easier to compare
your income or any
outcomes-- your grades,
et cetera-- compared to
what your friend has.
It's much harder to say how
much an extra $1,000 or having
$50,000 per year,
is that good or bad?
It depends a lot on what
you compare it against.
So what people tend
to do, and this
is exactly what Kahneman and
Tversky were postulating,
is that people
compare the outcomes
relative to reference points.
And again, we're going
to write this down
in more detail at the
beginning of next class,
but what Kahneman and
Tversky were postulating
were essentially two things.
They're postulating A,
there's a reference level
of consumption or any outcomes.
We can talk a little bit about
what actually is this reference
level, where it's coming from.
For now, we just assume there's
a reference level that people
compare the outcomes against.
And then against that,
outcomes are compared.
And in particular,
the function is
like steeper on the left
compared to the right, right?
Essentially losses
loom larger than gains.
So like going down by 10
units on the left or 1 unit
on the left is more
painful than going up
on the right relative to
those reference points.
OK?
And so that's all said.
So then what experimental
evidence do we in fact
have for that?
So one example-- so we have some
experimental evidence of this.
And I'm going to
show you next time
a bunch of different
examples of real choices,
starting from golfing,
to selling houses,
to lots of other outcomes.
But sort of the experimental
evidence, the earlier
experimental evidence
that people showed
were preferences
over risky gambles.
I showed you some of those
already, and then in particular
unwillingness to trade
different options compared
to like an alternative
option that I showed.
That's what people refer
to as the endowment effect.
So let me show you
first the gambles.
We already had
that in some sense.
These are like
essentially gambles.
People seem really
risk averse when
they are offered these gambles.
Kahneman and Tversky would
say people are essentially
loss averse.
People really dislike
the loss of $10
relative to the gain of $11.
We can explain that behavior.
And that's a very robust finding
that people decline these kinds
of types of gambles.
Kahneman and Tversky
would say that's evidence
of loss aversion.
Now, you might say these
are really small gambles.
Do we really care about them?
Well, once you do
this with $500, $550
or whatever, large amounts,
people also do the same.
It's hard to do this with
like real-world money
because it's quite
a bit of money.
It turns out there's
actually some studies who
do that as well.
They did this for real with MBA
students, financial analysts,
and rich investors.
And even those people like
tend to then turn down
those kinds of gambles.
So there seems to
be quite evidence
of lots of loss aversion.
Given the choices
between gains and losses,
people seem to really
dislike losses.
Now, what's the
endowment effect?
That's sort of the perhaps most
famous evidence in this domain.
It essentially is people, when
endowed with a certain item,
they really do
not like to trade.
And so the way you
would do an experiment--
you would give people
an item, and then
you ask them essentially-- and
a randomly selected fraction
of people are given an item.
And then either people
are offered the choice--
you would you either
keep your item,
or would you get another item
that's sort of the same value
overall?
Or, what people do is like
they have some experiments--
there's many of
these experiments--
you give some people one
item and some other people
another item, and
then see would you
like to trade with each other.
And what you see is
essentially people
are extremely
reluctant to trade.
There's many of these
kinds of examples.
Like, for example, so
one example-- sorry,
I skipped that.
One example is like if you
just give people an item--
usually it's like a mug--
if you give people a mug
and asked like, how much
do I have to pay you
to give me to sell me this mug?
People say large amounts.
They would say like $5.
If, instead, you asked
them, here's a mug.
Would you like to
purchase this mug?
And sort of controlling for how
much money they have and so on.
If you ask them like, would
you like to buy this mug,
people would say
like $2 or something.
It's the same mug, and
essentially their choice
depends on whether you give
them the mug versus whether you
endow them with the mug, which
is where the endowment effect
name comes from, or whether
you just sort of like
ask their willingness to
pay when they don't have it.
There's tons of
different experiments
that do exactly that.
Now, a different
version of that is like
so this one is about like
buying a mug, selling a mug,
buying and selling prices.
Different versions
of that is to say
you have a population of
students or different people,
and what you do
is essentially you
find two items that on average
have the same valuation.
Knetsch was doing that.
And so he had like
mugs and pens,
and he sort of calibrated such
that on average, when you just
asked, people's willingness
to pay for these mugs and pens
are like on average
roughly the same.
Of course, there's variation,
but on average it's the same.
And then you offered
half the students mugs
and half the students pens
and then offered in exchange.
He also offered in exchange
for an addition of $0.05
and saying like,
OK, maybe you're
just exactly indifferent.
So I'm giving you $0.05
in case you exchange.
And it turns out that the mug
people like to keep their mugs,
and the pen people like to keep
the pens, and 90% of people
do that.
That's one of the
most robust findings
in experimental economics.
There are some questions
on expectations.
Do people expect to keep the
mugs and so on and so forth?
There's some
complications for that,
but the basic result
is very robust
and has been shown in
many different settings.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So what's going on here?
Well, essentially,
the reference point
seems to be essentially
affected by ownership.
So if you own a mug,
your reference point
is owning a mug.
So now if I asked you, would
you like to sell me this mug?
Well, now you have
a loss of a mug.
So essentially, you're in
the lost domain of mugs.
So I have to pay you more money
to compensate you for that.
If, in contrast, you do not own
the mug, so like you have zero
mugs, your reference point is
zero mugs, and I'm asking you,
would you like to receive a
mug or like buy a mug from me,
then you're essentially
on the gain domain.
And sort of what I showed
you here previously--
one second.
So when I'm asking you
to purchase your mug,
essentially you're on the
left side of this figure.
You're in the loss domain.
Your marginal utility
of mugs is very high.
I have to pay you a lot of money
to receive the mug from you.
In contrast, if you have
zero mugs, I'm asking you,
would you like to
purchase a mug,
you're on the right side
of the suffering point.
So essentially now you're
in the gain domain.
Now you're not willing
to pay a lot of money
because you're gaining a mug.
On top of that, you also on
the gain loss domain of money,
but like I'm setting
that sort of aside.
Does that make any sense?
OK.
And so people hate losses
more than they like the gain.
So they stick with the mug.
And similarly, that's the
same thing for the pen owners.
There's lots of
different examples
of those kinds of behaviors.
For example, law
school students were
asked to assess compensation
for pain and suffering damages
in one study.
This is expected to last--
or in this example-- is
expected to last three years
and be quite unpleasant.
There's no impact on
earnings capacity.
For example, it would be extreme
stiffness in the upper back
and neck.
I think that would probably
affect your earning capacity,
but anyway let's assume
that's not the case.
So then some students
are led to imagine
they were being injured.
How much would you be
willing to pay to get better?
OK.
So your reference point
is like you're injured.
How much are you willing
to pay to get better?
And people said
151,448 on average.
Now, another group
of students was--
this is randomized-- was led
to imagine being uninjured.
Like, how much would I need to
pay you to accept the injury?
You're not injured.
Now I'm asking you, how
much are you willing to pay,
or how much do I
have to pay you,
how much do I have to compensate
you to accept this injury?
Now, you would think this
is like the same thing,
but what's your price
of not being injured?
The price of health should be
independent on which way I'm
asking you.
Turns out, when people
have their good health,
they're willing to pay
a lot more to keep it
or to not lose it compared to
like when they have lost it
and they want to regain it.
There's another
quite nice example.
I'm showing you here.
One second.
So in case you didn't
see, that was Dan Ariely,
who has several nice books.
One of them is
predictably irrational,
which is a quite nice read.
So there's lots of these kinds
of examples of loss aversion
or what's called the
endowment effect.
When people have
stuff essentially,
they're not willing to part it.
When they don't have it,
they're willing to pay less.
One nice thing that Ariely was
also talking about-- a little
bit about how
people then explain
these kinds of behaviors.
We're going to get
back to that in I
think lecture 20
or something, which
is about kind of like I
think what's going on here
is very obvious.
Potentially, people
are loss-averse
and they're randomized
into like gains or losses,
and that's kind of what's
explaining their behavior.
But people don't
necessarily understand
that they're being randomized
in one of the other conditions,
and they then sort of try
to explain their behavior
in various ways and saying, I
want to tell my grandchildren
about this.
But in some sense,
they're sort of
like rationalizing
their preferences
and they don't necessarily sort
of understand these stories,
and they don't
necessarily understand
where these preferences are
coming from even though we kind
of know, because the
person has been manipulated
into those kinds of choices.
We'll get back to that.
Now, the third part of Kahneman
and Tversky's prospect theory
of their paper is
essentially what's
called diminishing sensitivity.
I'm going to get back to this
and sort of write this down
in more detail on Monday,
but essentially it's
like people are risk-averse
in the gain domain,
but risk-loving and
the loss region.
What does it look like?
Essentially the
utility function is
a little bit different from
what I showed you before.
It's not only like
more steep on the left
relative to the reference
point compared to the right,
but it's also concave on the
right and convex on the left.
And what that gets you and
what that buys you essentially
is that people are risk
averse in the gain domain,
but people are risk-loving
in the loss domain,
and that sort of is needed
to be able to explain some
of the behaviors
that I showed you
early on in the Kahneman
and Tversky evidence.
So again, I'll tell you
about this in more detail
and sort of write this
down more precisely.
And then we're
going to talk about
like many different
applications.
And particularly, there's
the endowment effect
which is kind of what I talked
to you already about before.
There's labor
supply, employment,
and effort depending
on what people expect,
how much they earn.
They make different choices
about how many hours
they actually work depending
on the expectation,
whether it's above or
below a reference point.
People are reluctant
to sell their houses
if they're at a loss
compared to again
even for very similar houses.
And marathon-running
people are trying
to reach essentially
certain targets.
People like to be below
four hours or three
hours and the like.
There's the disposition
effect that we mentioned,
which essentially is
people like to sell winners
compared to losers.
And the insurance choice that
I already showed you before--
there's some evidence on
violence in the household.
The particular example is about
football or games essentially--
I think football games
where essentially depending
on whether people expected
a loss or win of their team
and when then a loss or a win
of the team actually happens,
there's more violence when there
are unexpected losses compared
to expected losses
which is, again,
consistent with loss aversion.
What's next?
So next we're going to talk
about many applications
of reference
dependence on Monday.
I'd like you to sort of read
the Kahneman and Tversky
paper, at least the
first pages to get
some sense of their work.
And then on
Wednesday, we're going
to start talking about
social preferences.
In particular, we can have
some experiments in class.
There's going to be
no readings for that.
There's the opportunity
to make money
in class, at least some of it.